>> Tucker: WELL MIKE ROWE HAS
LONG BEEN A CHAMPION OF
DIGNIFIED OLD FASHION LABOR, THE
KIND WHERE YOU GET DIRTY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE IS
CLOSE-MINDED OR ADVERSE TO
TECHNOLOGY.
HIS NEW SHOW "RETURNING THE
FAVOR" IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS ON FACEBOOK.
IMPRESSIVE.
TALENT RUNS IN HIS FAMILY.
MIKE'S MOTHER PEGGY HAS A BRAND
NEW BOOK COMING OUT TOMORROW
CALLED "ABOUT MY MOTHER."
TRUE STORIES OF A HORSE CRAZY
DAUGHTER AND HER BASEBALL
OBSESSED MOTHER.
MIKE AND PEGGY JOIN US TONIGHT.
WE ARE GRATEFUL THEY ARE HERE.
PEGGY, AS YOU KNOW, YOUR SON IS
AN FOLK HERO ON THIS SHOW.
BELOVED BY OUR VIEWERS.
>> YOU MADE IT WEIRD, TUCKER.
YOU MADE IT WEIRD!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU DIDN'T TELL ME IT WAS
THAT KIND OF SHOW.
>> SHE RATED IT JUST LIKE THAT.
>> Tucker: I CAN SEE HE IS YOUR
SON.
I'M SO IMPRESSED.
WHAT WAS HE LIKE WHEN HE WAS
YOUNGER?
>> YOU WON'T BELIEVE IT, BUT HE
WAS VERY SHY.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> HE WAS.
HE WAS -- IN FACT, WHEN SOMEBODY
WOULD COME TO THE FRONT DOOR
SOMETIMES, HE WOULD JUST DIVE
UNDER THE KITCHEN TABLE OR INTO
THE HALL CLOSET.
AND HE WAS A NEAT FREAK.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO GET DIRTY.
>> Tucker: I WAS GONNA ASK YOU
WHAT'S THE MOST EMBARRASSING
THING, BUT I THINK YOU TOLD US.
HE DOVE INTO THE HALL CLOSET.
HOW DID YOU GET HIM OUT?
>> WHEN THE PEOPLE LEFT, HE CAME
OUT.
>> GREAT.
HEADLINE TOMORROW, MIKE ROWE'S
MOM EXPLAINS HOW HE CAME OUT OF
THE CLOSET.
THANKS, TUCKER.
AWESOME JOB.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Tucker: I KNEW I COULD GET
IT.
MY SKILL AS AN INTERVIEWER.
IS THAT STORY IN THE BOOK,
MRS. ROWE?
>> NOT IN THIS BOOK, BUT IT'S IN
MY NEXT BOOK.
>> POPUP.
>> Tucker: A POPUP.
HAVE YOU READ THIS BOOK, MIKE?
>> READ IT?
I WROTE THE FORWARD TO IT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES YOU
AWESOME?
LAST TIME I WAS ON YOUR SHOW, WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT GOOD NEWS AND
I SAID, NEXT TIME I'M BRINGING
MY MOTHER AND YOU SAID, GO
AHEAD, AND YOU MEANT IT.
SO I'M SITTING HERE WITH MY
MOTHER BECAUSE SHE'S WRITEN THE
ULTIMATE BOOK OF GOOD NEWS.
THIS IS -- SHE'S BEEN WRITING ME
STORIES FOR YEAR.
I STARTED READING THEM ON
FACEBOOK.
PUBLISHERS FELL IN LOVE WITH
THEM AND A BOOK POPPED OUT.
THIS IS A BOOK, 19 STORIES ABOUT
GROWING UP NEXT TO HER MOTHER,
MY NANA.
THE TWO OF THEM ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING IN COMMON, LOVED EACH
OTHER DEARLY FOR 70 YEARS.
THIS BOOK IN THESE TIMES, IN MY
HUMBLE ESTIMATION, TUCKER -- I
DON'T WANT OVERSTATE IT.
THIS IS THE BALM OUR COUNTRY
NEEDS.
>> Tucker: B-A-L-M.
I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT.
I'M SINCERE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED.
I WOULD SAY ALL OF OUR VIEWERS,
NO MATTER WHO THEY VOTED FOR,
WHAT THEY THINK, WHO THEY PRAY
TO ARE FANS OF YOURS AND YOUR
MOM'S.
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE TO WRITE
THIS, MRS. ROWE?
>>IVE WRITING IT FOR YEARS,
ACTUALLY.
I HAVE WRITTEN SEVERAL STORIES
OVER THE YEARS AND PUBLISHED
THEM IN NEWSPAPERS AND
MAGAZINES.
AND THE RESPONSE WAS SO
POSITIVE.
PEOPLE LOVED A FEEL-GOOD STORY.
AND THEY'RE TRUE.
AND SO I DECIDED TO WRITE SOME
MORE AND PUT THEM TOGETHER IN A
BOOK.
>> DO YOU WANT THE TRUE STORY,
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: YES.
>> SHE COMES HOME FROM MACY'S
ONE DAY AND SAYS, YOU'LL NEVER
BELIEVE WHAT NANA DID.
SHE SAID, I WAS PUSHING HER IN
THE WHEELCHAIR AND SHE SAW AN
ORIOLES JERSEY.
SHE LEAPS OUT OF HER WHEELCHAIR,
TAKES OFF HER BLOUSE, PUTS ON
THE ORIOLES JERSEY.
MY MOTHER HAS A HEART ATTACK
SAYS, MOM, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
NANA SAYS, NOBODY CARES.
I'M AN OLD WOMAN IN A BRA.
RIGHT?
THEN KNOCKS THE MANNEQUIN OVER.
HEAD FALLS OFF, ROLLS DOWN THE
AISLE.
PEOPLE START SCATTERING.
MOM COMES HOME AND SAYS,
MICHAEL, I THINK THE TIME HAS
COME TO WRITE A BOOK ABOUT YOUR
GRANDMOTHER.
>> Tucker: NANA WAS NOT HIDING
IN THE HALL CLOSET WHEN PEOPLE
CAME OVER.
SHE WAS SELF-CONFIDENT.
>> IT SOUNDS UNBELIEVABLE, BUT
EVERY WORD WAS TRUE THAT HE JUST
SAID.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY,
EVERYTHING THE ROWE FAMILY TELLS
US, WE TAKE ATE FACE VALUE.
YOU ARE THE MOST BELIEVABLE
PEOPLE WE KNOW.
I HOPE YOU'LL BOTH COME BACK.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BY TWAY, ONE GOOD TURN
DESERVES ANOTHER.
MOM STARTED A NEW BOOK TODAY
"SHIP OF FOOLS."